what is it
i know what is it i just found out this
morning i'm so sorry what is it i'm
finding out now what is it
yeah
you go gilbert i know you go first
get cancelled
yeah
sorry did you know no he did i told you
you did on the phone
the day of
i remember oh
my god so kala
friday i told you i don't know that
splitting up together got cancelled
remember i said he's in a mood i'm in a
mood
and then oh that's what you complete the
weekend i know on friday i would have
immediately called you sir or you could
have said when you saw me today
because you had you were at the house
for an hour before we even started this
thing so what what's your story friend
hang on when you come in the house you
say hey bobby how are you
now i come straight here and start
setting everything up yeah he does
but i came in here to say hi i came here
to connect yeah to see if he was going
to say something do you know what's
going on in their individual lives
is it as devastating as losing their
jobs
yeah i had to watch what happened i had
to watch game of thrones oh there we go
that's very sad
how about you it's going to here i don't
want to upset her no i had a lovely
weekend yeah there we go hey but babe
okay so you know when the news happened
right yeah and i said
you know i was like because i was on my
way out the door when i found out and i
was like [ __ ] it i'm not gonna leave the
house let me stay here with you what can
i do for you
and you
you're very difficult to console and
you're very difficult to support so what
is the correct way
for someone who um
the way your style of being upset okay
here's the here's what it is
it's very simple
i got you food locked yeah that's the
jersey mike's that's that was a win
because i would have killed myself
without that i got a jersey and then you
lock eyes with me and you say
i'm sorry for your loss
and you just leave me alone for like 48
hours so i did what was right exactly
because i felt like maybe i wasn't doing
it no no i don't like being cuddled
or held i like to be completely alone
and in a cell
and into my own just like grim thoughts
i i i just never been
you know that way i i wish i was
different
i wish i could like be held and cry like
a baby no that's not true that's just
the way you cope and that's okay
everyone's different
um
but
so that happened and uh
you know
when people say stuff like
well when i don't when a door closes
another one opens
you know white people say that
exclusively
yeah yeah hey sorry white people
sometimes a room has one [ __ ] door
when that door closed it's just locked
in there forever no key right
you know or it's you know what here's
when they go spiritual when they go well
god has something else in store for you
or you know it was a man to be
really
that's the worst when you're feeling so
horrible and you just need a moment to
feel horrible
and the happiness bully police comes
through
and they just they have these one-liners
that are so [ __ ] cliche
and you just want to [ __ ] just punch
them in the anus
because you just don't want to hear it
you just want a moment to cry it out but
they won't let you
yeah then they start spilling that one
door closes the another one
using my voice guys
i love how we all went to that as the
go-to voice
so that this is so that happened and
then it got worse even so i was at the
comedy store last night and there's this
girl that i'm not going to say because i
love her
but she um she's a new regular she gets
spots all the time
now and i walked up to her i go hey
we're friends with the same people this
and then she's like yeah we did a job
together and i go what job is that or
remember that goldman sachs commercial
we did with mitch hurwitz if you don't
know mitch hurwitz it was he's he
created arrested development
and i remember doing a couple years ago
a series of commercials
for goldman sachs right
is that the one with like robert kelly
yeah but robert kelly was on them he
came here from new york it was fun
and they were like these long dialogue
scene kind of like commercials
and then like a couple of months after
that
i found out that they just didn't air
them
oh
right at all
and then i ran into mitch hurwitz in
hawaii
and i go what happened to those
commercials and he said i don't know i
don't remember i don't know no big deal
and then the lady the girl
from sunday last night
oh she goes you don't know it was you
no
what i go what happened
something about you showing your penis
not on set not on set
but it's so i'm like
i showed my penis maybe on like a tiger
belly vlog when you like stick it on
george's shoulder
or when ari when i stick the candy bar
in my bottle that was the same thing
that was around the same time yeah
that's also the beach sorry
fear doesn't like candy like you know
doesn't like snickers up the butt i know
but
yeah are you fear cornered you cornered
me and and lost me a job
that could have been i could have been
the new [ __ ] uh verizon guy or flo
progressive flow the face of gold
so anyway so then that happened and then
to make even matters worse
that night i come home i come to the
windows house to see